من الواضح أنني أقوم بالحد من أي إصابات ولكن
هناك دائمًا خطر
[موسيقى]
أن الحركة أو المنفرة تختلف
عن أي أداء آخر لأن
لدينا وقتًا خاصًا جدًا للإبداع
أعتقد أن مصدر إلهام الحرفي
من luttrell يأتي من الفنانين
أنفسهم  ينتمون إلى العديد من
الجنسيات المختلفة ولديهم
خلفيات مختلفة ، لذا يمكنك وضعهم
جميعًا معًا وكأنها
وصفة مستوحاة من
[موسيقى]
نقدم 10 عروض أسبوعيًا كل أسبوع ، لذا
يتعين علينا تعليمهم متابعة هذا
المستوى العالي من العروض العشرة أسبوعيًا  أو رمي
منطقة
[موسيقى
] لعبت دور فتاة اللؤلؤة وهي
الشخصية التي تؤمن بأن القصة التي
نتابعها تدور حول رحلتها ، لذلك
أشعر بالامتنان لكوني على خشبة المسرح لأشعر
وكأن الغرب هنا لمشاهدة
العرض إنها المرة الأولى  لهم
أنهم يخوضون هذه الرحلة كما
تعلم وأنا مسؤول عن قيادتهم
خلال هذه
[الموسيقى]
[تصفيق]